so we have an 80 000 cinema camera
versus a 4 000 mirrors camera how's the
comparison even fair how can the Sony
a7s3 stand against the rlx235 and how
comparable are they well that's
something I want to find out
this is a quick comparison between four
amazing cameras and some of the best
cameras at a time but each is for a
slightly different budget and in this
video I'm not trying to prove which
camera brand is better because each has
their own advantages and it's all about
your own needs and personal choices at
the end but this is a quick test we took
right after unboxing the area and
decided to share the results with anyone
curious
because let's be honest we all want to
know how these are powerful but tiny and
rather inexpensive mirrorless cameras
compared to one of the top Cinema
cameras out there
so we're gonna check how's the Ari
compared to other cameras and there's
some really unexpected results which
really made me feel surprised about the
red Komodo and all that by comparing a
couple aspects like noise performance
dynamic range underexposed Overexposed
and of course color because we all know
array for its amazing colors but how
does it stand against the red color
science which is also very famous for
its natural charm and what about
mirrorless how does a 4K email list
stand against one of the best cameras on
the market and what are the main
differences
so for this test we have different
lighting conditions artificial lighting
natural lighting exposed correctly
underexposed and Overexposed to push
these files and cameras in different
directions and see how they perform in
multiple situations
so lastly I'll test all of them with
Semi Power grades and I'll try to push
those colors to see which one will break
faster I want to thank my friend David
for modeling this video he's a very
talented filmmaker and I put a link to
his work in the description down below
also you can rent out any of these
cameras from nakedpixel.com and anything
from renting to full video production
they have everything so definitely check
them out these guys are top quality so
Link in description down below go check
them out
okay all cameras were shot at 24 FPS uh
150 of a second or 180 degree angle for
the cinema cameras at 5400 Kelvin and
all at base isos all on manual Cinema
lenses of a 35 millimeter equivalent
starting at C4 and exposure throughout
the video was adjusted by opening or
closing the t-stops so we'll lose a bit
of bokeh as we underexpose
unfortunately one thing to mention is
that being in a hurry we didn't notice
that we set the red Komodo to a 90
degree angle so the red will be
underexposed by One Stop compared to the
other cameras but still I will keep the
red in the game because there are some
very surprising results worth mentioning
since the red is shot in raw format I
can change the iso values inside DaVinci
to match exposures but still that won't
make it a fair comparison as the shorter
angle was higher than the other cameras
meaning less light hit the sensor so I
assume the red will perform better in a
dynamic range test and worse in the iso
performance test since it was
underexposed at least that's what I
thought before checking the final
footage so watch the whole video to see
exactly what's going on remember I put
chapters in the timeline so you can go
and check exactly what you're interested
in
of them were shot in the flattest lock
profile and white as color gamut for
most information these cameras have to
offer unfortunately we didn't have an
external monitor that can output Sony
raw at the time so the Sony was shot
only in 10 bit 422 while other cameras
are shot in raw 12 bed or even a 16-bit
raw so the Sony might have a little
disadvantage here in areas like color
reproduction and maybe in the noise
performance since the color sampling
will be inferior to the raw files but at
the same time Sony uses some internal
noise reduction which is an advantage
and most people don't shoot raw so that
will give most a7s3 users a clear
understanding of a real-life situation
usage oh by the way if you're a Sony
user I made a couple Sony film solution
recipes using the picture profile menu
which will get you better color and feel
my contrast right out of the box for
both sales and video check my website
for settings link description down below
okay as a first step I want to convert
the files to rec 709 using DaVinci's
color space transform to see exactly how
they look like and what are the specific
characters for each regarding the main
color differences dynamic range and
lastly noise and green levels but first
let's start with the blind test to be
non-biased about our color choices
first I want to show you how the footage
looks straight out of camera and how it
looks compared to rex09 so let's choose
your favorite then we'll look at some
close-ups to see the main color
differences
this is the color task with the correct
exposure besides the red which was set
at a 90 degree angle corrected by
raising the iso inside The DaVinci raw
processor all cameras are shot at 5400
Kelvin compare all four cameras and let
us know in the comments which is your
favorite
foreign
[Music]
now here are the results which one did
you choose let us know in the comments
right off the bat I can see the re is a
little bit on the green side compared to
the others which for me is not a big
problem because it's pretty easy to
correct and I know it's more common to
get in the green side with bigger
cameras and many Cinema cameras will
shift in that direction
once it converted to Rex of 09 it's
looking great the main differences
between color are pretty evident Ari and
Sony are actually looking quite similar
which is very unexpected for me at least
re being more on the warmer side but
they're almost identical the Reds and
the yellows on the Sony are a little bit
more saturated than the re and the
yellow is more shifted towards orange
while yellows on the Oreo look a little
bit more accurate real life
the greens are looking great on both and
the blues are very deep and saturated
which I really do like
red is having a lot less saturated
colors than the rest so to see exactly
what are the differences I will bump up
the saturation
red is going on a different direction
than ore and Sony having to saturate it
and Light blues together with more Olive
like greens and red shifted towards
orange I would say Canon is somewhere in
between red and the re having lighter
and a bit more the saturated yellows
which is very common trait for a Canon
camera their color science usually
relies on the saturating pretty heavily
the yellows and the greens to render
Perfect Skin zones for which they are
famously known for besides the greens
which are shifted towards still the rest
of the colors seem pretty similar to the
Sony and the Ari they all look really
nice and I like the color coming from
each of them and like I said they all
have their own personality and it's like
choosing your favorite kid and I can't
do that so let us know in the comments
which is your favorite one and I'm
really curious to find out
next comparison is dynamic range and
contrast
it's interesting to see how each camera
handles shadows and highlights
differently like I said they all been
shot into the flattest profile they have
but still some of them look darker While
others look brighter each of them has a
different recipe for the gamma values
and what I mean by this is if you look
at the array and the red compared to the
Canon and Sony they are the darkest you
can understand that from the red since
it was one stop underexposed by accident
but it's just curious to see how Airy
handles all the tones differently from
the rest
in a way I don't feel like the color
space transform is bringing all of them
to the same brightness or maybe each has
to be exposed differently to have the
same exact Rock 709 conversion so you
can get a little tricky to get the same
exposure by using the same settings on
all four cameras because each has their
own way of handling contrast and
highlights that's why I always recommend
exposing using the histogram waveform or
any similar tool your camera has because
only then you can exactly match all four
cameras but for this test we wanted to
keep all settings the same as closely as
possible
so it's best if you had time to really
test and get to know the cameras
beforehand to know exactly how to use
each in such a way that it's bringing
the most out of it we didn't had that
much time to experiment and this is our
first test comparing these four cameras
so please be kind in judging this video
because this is not a 100 scientific
test there are just some quick thoughts
on the main differences
so as you can see Ari had the most
details in the ungraded log but after
conversion the highlights are completely
blown out which doesn't seem fair to me
so what I'll do is manually grade all of
them and apply the same as curve to have
a fair comparison for the dynamic range
and a better understanding which one is
the winner here
surprising to see how the ungraded Ari
looks very much like the red which is
one stop underexposed one thing we
noticed while checking the false color
on the re it was really hard to blow
Ari's highlights even with lens wide
open at f2 and honestly I was skeptical
about this before checking the footage
on the desktop monitor because the red
for example was having a really hard
time preserving details in the
highlights and it seemed like it had the
worst dynamic range performance from the
bunch also taking into consideration
with its One Stop under exposure so that
is very interesting to see also because
red is bragging about high dynamic range
their cameras are capable of which only
proves how bad Reds dynamic range is in
reality because their sensors are made
to be exposed to the right so you would
probably lose all the details in the
highlights in the past I had many
problems with red sensor being too
grainy so I'm curious to see if it's
still an issue with red Komodo don't get
me wrong it's lovely filmic green which
I personally enjoy in most cases but for
high-end product commercial I'd rather
choose if I want a grain or not because
there's a high standard for clean images
so shooting stock commercial or low
light in general is very hard for red
and that is also maybe due to its high
megapixel count on a small aps-c sensor
I always ask myself why bother with 8K
if I have to apply so much noise
reduction to the final footage will look
more like 4K or even 2K at its best I
personally would rather have a 4K or
even a 2K camera that has a good low
light capability and great colors of
sampling because even movies at Cinemas
are projected at 2K and only sometimes
and 4K resolution so what's the big hype
after such high megapixel sensor sorry
guys but I just don't get it
so for the dynamic range comparison
Canada at first glance seems to be the
worst performer seems to be the worst
performer but after quickly analyzing
the overall image we can notice the
Shadows are more lifted and the
highlights are more blown out compared
to the other cameras and that is
probably because it has been shot in
c-lock 2 which is more focused on
preserving details in the shadows so
maybe with a new Canon r5c shot in
c-lock 2 you need to expose lower by One
Stop compared to the other Cinema
cameras to preserve details in the
highlights and get the same amount of
contrast in the shadows or either choose
siloc 3 which is a little bit more
contrasty but with a lower dynamic range
it's same with the Sony it seems faded
compared to re and red so to get the
same kind of a tonality over the image
try exposing more for the highlights
because Sony anyways is known to have
very good noise performance and again I
would say one stop lower to get the same
level of detail in the shadows and
highlights as the cinema cameras
redkamoto even unexposed by One Stop is
a bit short when it comes to dynamic
range compared to the re which is rather
unexpected just look at the white point
on the re and the white point of the red
there's a third of a stop difference
there if we set the red from 800 to 640
it's matching with Ari
[Music]
so Ken and Sony being somewhere in the
same boat somewhere about one or two
stops above red and re and we can see
the Shadows are lifted about the same
amount which only proves for my point
which is to get the same kind of a look
and dynamic range compared to the re
these stimulus cameras need to be
exposed lower by about one stop or maybe
two stops overall I think Ari and red
have softer transitions from Shadows to
Highlights which will give you a more
creamy look but it can match all four
cameras pretty easily if you know what
you're doing so that's it for dynamic
range let's check the noise performance
the exposure on these clips was lowered
by two stops by closing the aperture on
each lens the red is still at a 90
degree angle which is one exposure under
compared to the other cameras so keep
that in mind when comparing noise
for this test I'll create a custom mask
curve to lift the shadows and increase
the saturation to make the color
separation even more pronounced
Sony is known for its low light
capabilities and has in-camera noise
reduction which cannot be deactivated
but also it was only shot in 10 bit 422
which is of course last color
information compared to the raw footage
so this will be an interesting test and
I'm intrigued to find out which is the
best performer in this isolated scenario
[Music]
[Music]
Ari Canon and red need some noise
reduction by default since they are shot
and raw which doesn't offer any noise
reduction inside the camera so I want to
see how much noise reduction each camera
needs to get the noise removed it's nice
to have noise reduction in cameras since
applying it at post-production slows
down your playback considerably but it
would be cool to choose how much or if
Annie has to be applied onto your
footage so I would really appreciate
being able to disable this function if I
don't need it Sony
let's see which camera needs the most
noise reduction to get a clean image in
the noise reduction menu I've set the
mode to better
it seems like Canon is super noisy so
the noise reduction is lifted at about
maybe 70 or 80 to get rid of the chroma
noise which is kind of a lot
but there's still a lot of action going
in the shadows so for the artifacts to
disappear I need to hide them completing
the Shadows or apply more noise
reduction which will slow down our
workflow and make the footage look soft
so that's a pretty bad result if you ask
me red needs only about 34 for the
chroma noise but still there is some
filmic grain going in the shadows which
can be removed by the temporal noise
reduction but that will be a hefty task
for a graphics card but I'm very
surprised to see the red outperforming
the Canon r5c which for me is weird
taking into consideration they are both
AK but red is having a smaller APC
sensor and being underexposed by One
Stop compared to the Canon so that is
really nice and it might have performed
even better if exposed the same very
interesting and would say it rather
unexpected because from my past
experiences with the red Cinema cameras
I honestly would have said that Komodo
would perform the worst from all four
but it seems it has an advantage over
the Canon r5c
off the bat with the Ari I notice it's
extremely clean for not having any noise
reduction applied in the camera and to
get a clean image I always say you need
to raise the noise reduction to about 30
for the chroma noise to disappear but to
clean out the artifacts completely some
temporal noise will be needed but even
without its super super clean and has
very little grain or lumino noise so
that's great
the Sony a7s3 already having some noise
reduction applied in camera seems to
have more details in the shadows
compared to the re but the color sub
sampling is a little bit worse right off
the bat and after lifting the Shadows I
can notice more color noise than the
other raw format and some slight
artifacts going in the shadows as for
the noise production you only need to
lift it to about 17 to get the color
noise removed and about 30 to get rid of
the grain so those are great results
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
but even after applying 50 on the noise
reduction in the re and the Sony I
always say the Sony has more artifacts
than the re and that is maybe because of
the 10-bit 422 format which is more
prone to artifact choosing raw recording
I assume will solve this issue much
easier because it has more color
information but I cannot confirm this
most of them are pretty clean take it
into consideration this was underexposed
and shot for the highlights and not for
the subject so generally speaking all
that noise should be covered and hidden
in the shadows after color grading so
right now I'm pushing the files just for
the sake of testing and seeing the
limits of each camera
we saw comparison for color dynamic
range contrast differences and ISO
performance only thing left for testing
is how well they hold up in color so how
much does it take to break each of these
files at this point we realized the
mistake of shooting the red at 90 degree
angle but we didn't had any more time to
reshoot all the footage that day so we
just corrected the settings for the last
shot and kept the files as they were
because I didn't even have the intention
to make a YouTube video about this
initially we made this quick comparison
for ourselves because we just unboxed
their Ariel Alexa 35 and we're super
excited to see what the camera is
capable of and to see the main
differences between all these four
camera models but I figured since the
videos already made I will create a
YouTube version for anybody interested
to see the results as well so take it as
it is I know it's not perfect nor 100
accurate but definitely it's an
interesting and informative video to see
all the cameras strengths and weaknesses
you can rent each of these cameras from
nakedpixel.com
so as a last test I'll use one of my
film power grades called the cine Rec 16
millimeter film print and we'll make
some sloppy and ridiculous color grading
adjustments to push the files to the
limits
to apply the cinerex 16 millimeter you
can either drag and drop it on top of
your desired node color correct manually
and then adjust contrast and saturation
on your own liking or use the color
space transform to translate into Rex
709 and ensure colors are right where
they're supposed to be
let me apply and match the contrast on
all four of them
this is a film print which I've created
for natural and analog film look and it
comes in 14 different color presets for
daytime and nighttime situations if
you're interested in the cine rack 60
millimeter film print you can download
it from my website link in description
down below go check them out yeah okay
so after applying the film power grid
they all look great I wouldn't expect
less from them and just by adjusting
everything in a normal everyday
situation nothing is supposed to go bad
but let's Force these babies just a bit
to see what are the differences and how
much do we need to push it to go bad
of course you wouldn't do this to any
kind of grade normally because it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever but
I'm just trying to make a point here to
see what are the differences between
four six thousand cameras and an 80 000
cinema camera and I'm sure there are
many many ways of testing these cameras
and in each test you will get slightly
different results but I'll just quickly
match the exposure and contrast for a
fair comparison and afterwards I'll make
a very radical color shift between two
colors to Make Them Fall Apart so we can
see the 10 bit has only 422 color sub
sampling and it's the most affected
which I'm not sure if you can see
because of YouTube compression the
difference is small but it's there again
this probably is not so relevant in your
workflow because nobody will do such a
great I'm just doing these adjustments
out of curiosity to experiment and see
exactly how well each camera performs
there are so many ways of testing uh
this and it all depends on so many
factors like each camera model and color
space has different weaknesses in color
so one of these dramatic color shifts
might affect One camera more than the
other so if we change the position of
the nodes to another color transition
then maybe the results will be different
if you want a more in-depth comparison
let me know in the comments what you
like to see and we might make another
video where we shoot some real live
footage and see how each camera Compares
in more challenging situations
so after trying multiple tests and
pushing different color channels I came
to the conclusion that red Komodo seems
to hold up its best in most situations
and that is to be expected since it's
outputting 16-bit raw footage I would
never apply anything like this in my
grades this is just an extreme test to
see which camera is holding better and
by how much
differences are very small to be honest
so definitely very interesting to see
all four cameras up against each other
with surprising results honestly red
Komodo surprised me the most in both
good and bad ways because I didn't
expect it to have lower dynamic range
underexposed by One Stop nor did I think
it will have a better low-light
performance than the Canon r5c but in
the same time it has the 16-bit output
compared to the Canon r5c a little bit
raw so that is a color Advantage which
might result in better noise performance
also I did not expect this Sony a7s III
to be so close in color with the re
Alexa 35 but let's not forget at the end
of the day it's not a camera that
matters the most but the vision and the
knowledge behind it they are all amazing
cameras and we are so lucky to live in
these times where we can enjoy such
quality coming from smaller format
cameras as well as more interesting
Cinema cameras if you're interested in
the city Rex 16 millimeter film print
there's a link in description down below
where you can find all my film products
so that's it for today but I have some
interesting tutorials coming next couple
weeks together with some film simulation
recipes for Sony cameras so till next
time take care and remember have fun see
ya
[Music]
foreign
[Music]